[Music]
oh my god
what was that what just came out of his
head is it a piercing that is my
only potential doctory thing that i
could see happening there 262 000 aged
17 let's see
wait i don't understand did he sell an
organ get a medical mistake
made on him therefore suing the practice
and getting medical malpractice do you
think he's jazzed on a medical
malpractice
settlement i don't know where he he's
joking and he's trying to make it like
he did get
surgery to sell in oregon oh yeah i
think it's a joke i'm not buying it
this looks like exophthalmos where the
eye actually starts protruding in front
of the eye socket
generally we talk about this in graves
disease which is a thyroid disorder
where your own body's
immune system starts attacking certain
parts of your body including the thyroid
as well as the muscles surrounding the
eye which actually force the eye out it
also could be a congenital variation
where you're just born with this type of
appearance wrinkles always occur
opposite of how the muscles laid out
for example if you see the frontalis
muscle goes
across your forehead then the wrinkles
will go like that
how do we relax those muscles so we need
to go with the muscle
and relax it so in the forehead area it
would be like that
in the mouth area it would be like that
for massage i just like it when people
massage my face period i feel like
that's an under
massaged and underappreciated area
specifically the masseter muscle
like if you massage this for me oh my
god just try it right now
as you're watching this video try
massaging your masseter
like while you're masticating
all right it's getting weird among the
weirdest things i've ever done
is that bear wow that's good are they
making him a pokemon
did they make him a pokemon card i think
they just made his instagram account
oh i thought that was a pokemon card
what power would bear have if he was a
pokemon
slobber attack and floof
blow dr mike you've ruined
watching any medical drama or any
medical scene for me
ever in the history of forever it's
funny i'm watching my own tick tock on a
tick tock review this is like conception
i'm reacting to my reaction reacting to
her reaction to my
medical drama reactions people do tell
me
i have ruined medical traumas for them
at the same time some people said that
they are now ruining it for their own
family members by yelling out chest
compressions chest compressions chest
compressions but that chest compressions
line has saved lives
no joke i get messages about this all
the time so yes
i would trade a little decrease in
reputational value for some of these
medical dramas for a life saved or two
this video is about to be a thirst trap
but specifically tailored for nurses
cool you are the underappreciated
backbone of the medical community and i
want to show you some appreciation
nurses you get an extra shout out but
also
medical lab workers respiratory
therapists and techs
engineering clinical engineering staff
pharmacists
cmas environmental staff there's so many
underappreciated medical workers
seriously i want to thank all of you for
the work that you've done during this
pandemic and
always
[Music]
is it weird that i saw the veins and the
cat at the same time and i got equally
excited for both
just just just putting a feeler out
there what would it be like
if bear had a cat friend bam if i got
you a cat or
kitten would you want it are you
thinking about it like a little kitty
that just comes and like plays with you
might
might scratch you a little bit at first
but i think you guys will get along
yeah you want a little kitty yeah you
want a little kitty
yeah high five if you want a kid yeah
you want a kitty hey
ems brought in this guy bp's crashing
maps less than 50.
i feel like i need to slowly translate
this ems emergency medical services
brought in this guy blood pressure is
crashing mean arterial pressure is less
than 50. is o2 sat okay o2 is oxygen
saturation
h of copd a past medical history of
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
pe in the setting of dvt with underlying
ipf oh what's ipf uh nope uh but
pulmonary embolism in the setting of
deep vein thrombosis
with underlying ipf idiopathic pulmonary
fibrosis
no way i was gonna say that's your rare
diagnosis
how's the bmp the bmp is the basic
metabolic panel okay now they're just
throwing acronyms around to throw across
yeah he's got cad he's got cad status
post pci which means he's got coronary
arterial disease
status post meaning after pci which
means catheterization
with prior cabbage meaning coronary
arterial bypass graft it's like open
heart surgery
and hfref meaning heart failure with
reduced ejection
fraction as opposed to heart failure
with preserved ejection fraction wtf
idk btw is your shift almost over oh
hell no
omg that was stressful and we're moving
on to a third movement
go ahead of the moonlight sonata okay go
ahead
i don't know it that's fine
[Music]
wow that was incredible
there's something written there about
dementia i'm not sure if this patient
has dementia
and is still able to play the piano
because the area
for musical recollection is in a
different area
of where we keep memories and like our
cognitive decisions
day in and day out also there's a layer
of muscle memory involved there this is
really cool to see and inspiring at the
same time
fun fact there's actually only four
bands in my mouth there's just
two very large ones and two thick boys
you know i am not an orthodontist
i don't know enough about braces to know
why this is happening i almost want to
like ask one of my dentist friends to
see why that
why they would be needed to be
instituted
whoa that's intense your orthodontist is
making you do full mouth settling
elastics and here's why
okay we're gonna get an explanation
looks like i don't need to call my
dentist friends
if you get towards the end of braces
your orthodontist will have you hook up
what are called settling rubber bands to
help the bite fit together better most
of the time we just use them on the
sides of the mouth like this but
lucky you your orthodontist is making
rhythm on all your teeth that's a little
rough but your bite's gonna turn out
awesome having an underbite an overbite
can
cause problems down the line in terms of
tooth damage uh jaw pain tmd disorders
it's funny i said tmd disorders when
it's actually just tmd
and the d is disorder
[Music]
wow
[Music]
the pituitary gland secretes the growth
hormone which then can affect
certain bones this is mainly going to
happen in areas outside of of the long
bones after you get older
simply because the growth plates have
fused in the long bones that's why you
get a very specific
phenotype meaning look uh when you have
a pituitary tumor after your growth
plates have fused what's a really weird
thing that your body
does that you're not sure anybody else's
body does
oh that's actually pretty interesting
i've never seen that before huh
i don't know what to make of that
there's some kind of just like cartilage
there look human bodies have all sorts
of variations on them and that's cool
that's what makes medicine interesting
there's patients who have dextrocardio
where
the heart is instead of being slightly
on the left side is slightly on the
right side
how cool is that i can confidently
say that i almost died on that high
i've never seen this in real life before
my body tried to get me to clean my
pants a number of times
to warm me up if your body senses that
you're losing heat
and it's having trouble keeping you at a
certain temperature
it's going to divert the warm blood away
from
areas that are not immediately crucial
to your survival like your lips like
your fingers like your toes so this
blue is dangerous the fact that she's
shaking so vigorously is her body
desperately trying to warm up and keep
warm it's like a form of early
hypothermia
i think you desperately need to get a
reflective blanket on her some warmth
turn
on that heat in that car and uh get some
fluids in you as well
oh my god i would freak out right now
did you put this in there because of my
spider story oh my god
i had a beautiful red audi tts and i was
driving and i stopped at a stop sign and
as soon as i let go of the break
i saw a big green spider i saw it and i
panicked
and i instead of hitting it or pushing
it away i grabbed my wallet
and hit it bad idea because as i did
that i didn't realize
i also turned the steering wheel a
little bit too far
without even realizing when i made
contact with the spider i also made
contact with the front right side of my
headlight
with the back left side of the van that
was parked on the street across from me
and i started screaming and crying and
people came out and they said what are
you doing you just hit into our car in
the middle of the street in the middle
of the daytime for no reason
and i said but there was a spider here's
the worst part of the story
calling my russian angry soviet father
to tell him that this happened and then
the firefighters coming to make sure
that i'm okay
telling them the story and having them
all laugh at me then the paramedics and
emts coming and hearing the story and
laughing at me and then calling my
insurance company and telling them the
story and having them laugh at me
i'm not telling that story anymore shark
tank medical pitches can sometimes go
overboard
pun intended check out my reviews here
of some
very wild shark tank medical pitches and
as always
you stay happy and healthy
[Music]